hi there steve kaufman
efficiency and language learning is
extremely important i learned that when
studying chinese
45 or 48 years ago
the more efficient you are
because there's so much time involved
even a 50 increase in efficiency has a
big impact and the faster you can learn
the language the more efficient and the
more intense you're learning experience
the better you're going to learn that
was my experience 48 years ago
um
so how do we want to spend our time i
checked out duolingo
duolingo is extremely well designed
it's fun it's like a game
so you're playing a game and at the same
time you're discovering a language
you're discovering the word for bread
and eat and
drink and cow and things like this
so is that an efficient way to learn a
language
in my view it has a big advantage in
that it's it's a gamified approach it's
fun and you do learn
something
i don't think in terms of time
efficiency it's not something that i
would spend a lot of time with
because
my feeling is that efficient language
learning consists of exposing yourself
to
word dense material the greater the
density of words the better therefore i
prefer
listening audio material to
visual videos
whenever i've listened to a story or a
novel in an audiobook format and then
watch the movie i find the audiobook
format especially if the text is
available to me
as much more intense and much more
effective in terms of building
vocabulary because building vocabulary
is key
as i've said before you don't need one
or two thousand words in order to speak
a language you need ten thousand words
you need lots of words
believe me i've been there i've gone to
a country with a thousand words and i
got nowhere couldn't understand what
they were saying and they quickly
switched to english on me or i didn't
have the patience to stay with me so
uh duolingo but by all means you should
try it and i'd be interested in hearing
other people's uh impressions i think
it's a good way to get started in a
language
but you know also efficiency it's not
only that the
high word density material that i listen
to and read
is more efficient in terms of acquiring
the language getting used to the
language it's also that it's so much
easier to organize duolingo i have to
sit in front of either my iphone or my
computer and play that game as enjoyable
as it may be however
like i have a visitor coming from the
czech republic i've been reviewing my
check i go on the internet i
download tolki cesco minilosti some new
episodes i can read them on link i can
listen to them while walking the dog
while while driving so that it's a
better use of my time i can do it while
doing other things if i couldn't simply
listen for an hour or more a day
i couldn't learn all these languages so
it's just the portability of listening
that's so powerful and then when you
couple it with reading and here again
all of the material that i've downloaded
from the internet in czech i've now got
it ready to go on my ipad so that i can
do my link offline on the plane i have
to fly i should mention i have to fly to
edmondson tonight
so in terms of efficiency i see duolingo
as a great introduction to the language
i think
the simple fact that books
uh reading and listening is just the
most efficient way and when you have the
opportunity you speak but in the
meantime you are able to spend
free time dead time
in a very efficient way simply by
listening and reading so and i would
look forward to your comments on
duolingo i've only spent an hour on it i
can't say that you know many people i i
checked some reviews on the internet
there's people who have not been on it
for years and have much more in-depth
things to say and you can check those
out on the internet as well
thank you for listening bye